herr hans armin laschet ist beim
nachdenken über ostern offensichtlich
vorsichtiger geworden sie nicht
einer von ihnen beiden kann aber
eigentlich nur recht haben aber erstmal
bin ich weiterhin natürlich vorsichtig
im übrigen waren wir im saarland
diejenigen die als allererstes damals
betroffen von der welle die auch von
frankreich kamen schulen geschlossen
haben in der nacht wir haben als erstes
ausgangs beschränkungen gemacht sind
auch dafür kritisiert worden aber wir
haben auch damals als erstes das
demonstrationsrecht wieder eingeführt
weil wir gesagt haben dass grundrechte
auch bei london maßnahmen eine rolle
spielen müssen und wir haben mehrere
gerichtsentscheide gehabt auch im
saarland die uns gesagt haben eine reine
orientierung an instanzen ist nicht
hinreichend das muss die lage in den
krankenhäusern in den griff genommen
werden und insofern ist nun aber auch
dramatisch die ist derzeit viel tadel
ist im saarland unter kontrolle bleiben
wir noch mal ganz kurz beim bund und dem
vorschlag dass es einen brücken lockdown
geben soll
armin laschet schlägt dem vor
folgen sie ihren parteivorsitzenden ich
kann für das saarland keinen brücken
lockdown verhängen selbst wenn ich das
wollte weil oberverwaltungsgericht in
saarlouis zum beispiel gesagt hat ich
darf bei vergleichbarer incidents
entwicklung wie jetzt auch nicht einfach
unkonditioniert geschäfte schließen und
wir mehrfach auch gesagt bekommen haben
dass es einen zusammenhang geben muss
zwischen maßnahmen und
infektionsgeschehen aber auch der
belastung des gesundheitswesen und dem
zustand letztendlich auch was denn im
fortschritt an
wir impfen sehr stark wir sind vorne in
der frage wieviel impfstoffe sind
bereits verabreicht worden
wir testen mittlerweile sehr stark das
haben wir gelernt dadurch dass wir
aufgrund der hohen incident in unserem
nachbar departement in frankreich eben
auch betroffen waren und haben gespürt
dass wir obwohl neben uns instanzen von
270 300 in frankreich in luxemburg auch
deutlich über 200 herrschen bei offenen
grenzen durch das testen die instanzen
konstant und stabil auch unter 100
halten konnten
und deswegen setzen wir auf diese massen
testung das modell ist nicht öffnung
das modell heißt dass an die stelle von
kontakt beschränkungen test erfordernis
treten sie anreize für tests haben sie
heute eine inzidenz korrigieren sie mich
sieben tage incidents von 97,4 die magen
war mal wesentlich geringer da sind 277
fälle dazugekommen und die
bundeskanzlerin sagte schon vor
anderthalb wochen das was sie da tun ist
ein echtes wagnis und wahrscheinlich
wird sie jetzt auch das erfinden was wir
nun heute wissen oder was ich immer mehr
herausschält nämlich dass der bund gerne
mehr macht übernehmen möchte über oder
mehr einheitlichkeit kann man
freundlicher formulieren haben möchte
über das was ihn einst in den ländern
geschieht das heißt das was die
kanzlerin der vorschlägt steht sie auch
gegen ihn vor nein das würde ich so
nicht sagen das problem ist dass wir
bisweilen in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz es nicht
geschafft haben einen einheitlichen
maßstab festzulegen wir haben zwar
verbindliche kriterien und auch stufen
pläne festgelegten übrigen folgt das
saarland modell ja exakt diesen
festgelegten stufen blender ist nichts
dabei was nicht festgelegt ist das
modellhafte ist eben dass viele testen
was wir jetzt vorantreiben an der see
und im übrigen habe ich nichts gegen
einen einheitlichen maßstab ganz im
gegenteil ich glaube es würde erst
gingen erleichtern weil sie haben jetzt
zweimal gerichte erwähnt sie würden
unter anderem von ihren eigenen
verwaltungs und verfassungsgerichten
nicht regelmäßig aufgefordert anders zu
entscheiden so würde es sogar hell ich
glaube man darf es nicht so sehen dass
man gerichtsentscheidungen aushebelt ich
glaube dass die gerichtsentscheidungen
auch etwas damit zu tun haben dass er
mittlerweile seit über einem jahr an
dieser pandemie sind und der faktor zeit
muss dabei eine rolle spielen ist ein
unterschied ob ich einen harten lockdown
machte zu beginn einer pandemie oder ob
ich je nach einem jahr mache wo ganze
kohorten von kindern letztendlich nicht
in der schule waren und in
bildungsansprüche auch verloren gegangen
sind ich glaube man muss da schon auch
darauf achten wo generationen oder eine
generation eine ganze generation in
alten pflegeheimen im moment unter
kontakt armut leidet natürlich haben wir
den lebenszeit gegeben dadurch dass wir
auch die lok downs gemacht haben und
kontakte reduziert haben dafür haben wir
das getan aber im moment haben wir eine
situation wo wir menschen auch dauernd
wieder in harte lockdown zu bringen
obwohl es eben auch mildere mittel gibt
und wir sind nicht nur gerichtlich
sondern wir sind auch als politiker
innen verpflichtet mildere mittel zu
suchen versuchen das ist die etwas was
sie tun können sind wir müssen mildere
mittel finden und sie ausprobieren und
das ist das was wir tun im saarland
modell aber mit aller vorsicht wenn wir
über 100 gehen springt die ampel auf
gelb
wenn es eine sollten sie bei tun sie
sind jetzt bei 97,4 wenn wir drei tage
über 100 sind wir sind bislang über 100
gewesen den letzten wochen dann werden
wir die ampel auf gelb stellen es wird
noch mehr test pflichten geben etwa im
einzelhandel dann und es wird täglich
auch kontrolliert werden wie ist die
lage in den intensivstationen und dann
wird wenn eine überlastung droht sofort
auch die notbremse gezogen wir fahren
auch nicht über rot sahen wir werden
dort an dieser stelle anhalten ist ein
sehr vorsichtiges peter tschentscher ist
bei uns der regierende bürgermeister von
hamburg und medizin molekularbiologe
sind sie im zweit und neben beruf und
korrekt heißen sie natürlich ist der
bürgermeister der schönen stadt hamburg
viele menschen wären froh wenn das
experiment von herrn hans glücken würde
wünschen sie ihren erfolg wünschen kann
man sich das aber ich bin sehr skeptisch
dass das erfolgreich ist auch in
tübingen hat man ja versucht die
schnelltests zu nutzen um eröffnungen zu
machen und ich glaube das ist ein irrtum
dass das funktioniert weil die
schnelltests nicht die sicherheit haben
die einige damit verbinden das ist so
dass wir damit bestehende dinge sicherer
machen können aber zusätzliche öffnung
jetzt damit zu begründen ist eigentlich
nicht das was wir an strategie haben sie
herrn genau das was die kanzlerin sagt
verstehen sie ihren impuls anzuregen das
meer
vom bund in dieser jetzigen pandemie
lage entschieden wird
das ist fast schon über die parlamente
dann gegebenenfalls auch mit oder ohne
bundesratszustimmung das wird sich noch
weisen
mehr macht aus dem bund gebe also ich
kenne jetzt nicht die konkreten plan
sich frau merkel da schmiedet
ich höre nur unterschiedliche dinge
darüber es geht uns aber nicht darum
dass wir die mildeste mittel finden
sondern wir müssen wirksame mittel
einsetzen und deswegen haben wir in
hamburg jetzt die ausgangs
beschränkungen die ausgangssperre dazu
genommen wir haben eine sehr scharfe
kontakt beschränkung weil wenn man mal
ab unabhängig von den juristischen
politischen und sonstigen dingen mal auf
die lage guckt dann ist es überall so
dass wir die britische mutation die
infektiöser ist die vermutlich zu
schweren erkrankungen führt haben wir
haben jetzt über die ostertage durchaus
eine geringere incidents die wir
nachweisen aber das wird sehr
wahrscheinlich auch mit dieser feiertag
situation zusammenhängen und deswegen
müssen wir damit rechnen dass wir ihn
weitere ernste probleme kommen wenn wir
jetzt nicht konsequent die infektions
lage dämpfen
und deswegen haben wir eigentlich
gemeinsam noch vor ostern schon
beschlossen wir brauchen noch etwas
zusätzliches über das konzept was wir
haben und deswegen bin ich schon
erstaunt dass selbst die dinge die wir
beschlossen haben nicht sehr konsequent
umgesetzt werde übrigens nicht nur im
saarland
bezogen auf diese modell überlegungen
sondern zum beispiel auch in bayern die
gerade jetzt schließen dass man über 100
den einzelhandel öffnen darf dann
klicken 100 bis 200 aber das ist
ausdrücklich nicht das was wir
vereinbart haben und deswegen ich
wünsche mir schon dass wir jetzt
wirklich absolut also in
nordrhein-westfalen herr laschet ist
gescholten worden werden am montag die
schulen wieder schließen und bayern
macht zwischen 100 und 200 incidents
kriegen einzelhandel oft in abweichung
von dem konzept dass wir in der liga
beschlossen haben das gilt auch für
manch eine kontakt beschränkung die wir
eigentlich für diesen bereich vorgesehen
haben insofern müssen wir jetzt glaube
ich schon den ernst der lage erkennen
und was ich frau bringt man die
mediziner hier in dieser runde werden
vielleicht noch mal was sagen die
intensivstation in hamburg sind derzeit
jetzt schon so ausgelastet wie zum zum
höchststand der zweiten welle
und das macht mir sorgen dass wir
möglicherweise jetzt zu spät mit unseren
maßnahmen ins werk kommen und deswegen
haben wir in hamburg noch vor ostern
diese sehr weitreichenden maßnahmen
beschlossen und haben muss man sich
ungefähr so die mpk die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vorstellen
dass sie beschlüsse anders verstehen als
ernst aber wir sind ja alle
aufgeschrieben das was ich jetzt gerade
sagen das ist ja kann man nachvollziehen
jahren ist für schriftlich visiert das
ist doch jetzt schon sehen dass wir
jetzt versuchen sollten diese beschlüsse
einheitlich umzusetzen ich bin auch der
meinung dass wir darüber hinaus noch den
er praktisch schränken bei den
ladenöffnung beim einzelhandel und eben
auch bei den ausgangs beschränkungen
einheitliche regeln brauchen weil die
leute mittlerweile auch verärgert sind
dass sie gar nicht mehr wissen was geht
jetzt gerade bei mir was gilt im
nachbarlandkreis und dieser
flickenteppich führt auch zur mobilität
die wir in der pandemie bekämpfung eben
nicht gelungen nicht brauchen kann
das finde ich im übrigen auch aber ich
will doch an der stelle noch mal sagen
dass das saarland modell komplett den
beschlüssen der mpk folgt dass der
einzelhandel geöffnet worden
es geht auf ein gerichtsbeschluss des
ovg saarlouis zurück und wenn ich
richtig informiert bin sind auch die
dinge die in bayern jetzt beschlossen
worden letztendlich ausschluss von
gerichtsentscheidungen und es gehört
eben auch zur bewältigung einer solchen
pandemie dazu und zu unserem
demokratischen rechtsstaat dass wir eben
auch gerichtsentscheidungen nicht nur
akzeptieren müssen sondern sie
berücksichtigen müssen in unseren
entscheidungen ich will auch noch mal
sagen mir geht es nicht darum das
mildeste mittel zu suchen mir geht es
darum mildere mittel die gleich wirksam
sind zu finden und das ist ein auftrag
den wir verfassungsgemäß haben auch
ausführen müssen männer wie bringt man
es bei uns geologen tu braunschweig
sie sind auch in dem beraterstab der
bundesregierung verbringt man und sie
haben vehement eigentlich seit januar
darum
das ist endlich wie die kanzlerin sagte
nun zusätzlich zum lockdown oder zu eben
unserem unserer notbremse etwas
zusätzliches geben muss stimmen sie
herrn lasse zu dass wir einen briten
lockdown brauchen also ich würde sagen
ich rede seit letztem sommer davon dass
wir die infektionszahlen niedrig halten
wir stehen aber ganz besonders
ja da kann das in den medien noch mal
stärker vor aber die wissenschaft hat ja
auch schon im letzten herbst sind klar
gewarnt die zahlen steigen und je früher
wir handeln desto mehr menschen leben
können wir retten und je konsequenter
wir handeln desto kürzer dauern diese
maßnahmen auch und ich glaube das ist
ein großes problem was passiert ist es
wurde zögerlich gehandelt man hat mal
geschaut wie sich die zahlen entwickelt
haben und gesagt gut in zwei wochen
schauen wir mal wie es aussieht aber es
gab nie diese langfristige perspektive
da oder ein klar formuliertes ziel wir
wollen wir eigentlich hin in diesem land
und was ist denn was sind denn
strategien die gut funktioniert haben
schauen wir doch mal in andere länder
und das hat gefehlt und waren wir im
januar ja schon im lockdown deutschen
lockdown und wir haben klar appelliert
im januar dass diese neue variante
kommen wird dass sie das bios was davor
passiert hat überholen wird verdrängen
wird und dass sie eigenschaften hat die
die uns die bekämpfung der pandemie noch
mal richtig schwer machen
und das wurde nicht gehört das muss man
ja einfach mal so klar sagen und es
wurde nicht nur nicht gehört sondern es
wurde das gegenteil gemacht wir haben
geöffnet bereiche in einer phase wo die
instanzen noch viel zu hoch waren wir
waren hier auf dem absteigenden ast zwar
eigentlich die richtige richtung und
unser vorschlag war warum das jetzt
nicht noch mal effizienter gestalten mit
einem klaren ziel mit guter
kommunikation mit falco wird mit
vermehrtem testen dass das ganze einfach
schneller geht wir wollen doch
alle aus dem lockt dann wieder raus und
das wollen wir aber auch nachhaltig also
wir wollen die zahlen so weit runter
drücken dass wir den erwert den
berühmten er wert auf dauer auch unter 1
halten können und das können wir indem
wir zum beispiel weiterhin gut testen
weiterhin natürlich auch masken tragen
also kostet die nächste logische tage
verbringen album ist auch total wichtig
es ist das was asiatischer wenn man nur
wenn und die zahlen niedrig sind dennoch
die frage hat sich an unserer situation
und das ist das argument von herrn hans
nicht tatsächlich etwas geändert eben
weil wir endlich diese tests haben auf
die wir ja seit monaten warten oder
monate lang leiter erwarteten und jetzt
in überschaubarer größenordnung haben
wir uns impfen hat sich an unserer
situation nicht etwas geändert
das immer da aber es ist zu langsam und
höhere dritte welle nicht mehr aufhalten
können das wird nicht gelingen sagen die
noch einmal eine frage jetzt kennt diese
situation des testen ist super ergebnis
aber nur eins von vielen mitteln die wir
haben und testen allein reicht nicht
das haben uns beispiele gezeigt
österreicher das versucht österreich hat
immer noch bei hohen instanzen geöffnet
hat die zeit tatsächlich auch ganz gut
unten halten könne zeit lang aber es ist
ihnen nicht nachhaltig gelungen und das
ist ja das was mich so verrückt macht in
dieser pandemie keine spricht mal davon
was ist eigentlich in ein paar monaten
ich werde doch mit der strategie die wir
gerade fahren in einem dauer lockdown
für den rest des jahres wenn ich pech
habe mich befinden und genau davor
wollen wir die wissenschaft diese
gesellschaft bewahren
wir wollen im sommer bereiche wirklich
öffnen können ohne sie gleich wieder
schließen zu müssen also noch mal die
frage ob sie denken
es bräuchte einen lockt es bräuchte
zusätzlich zu der notbremse einen doktor
also ich glaube es braucht erstmal ein
klares ziel
wo wollen wir eigentlich hin und das
klare dafür muss man auch erstmal sehen
hat es denn jetzt eigentlich
funktioniert was wir gemacht haben sind
wir zufrieden mit der situation einmal
unter demenz beratung rein kommen lassen
wie sind wir hier eigentlich gefahren
und wie
wie wird es weitergehen wenn wir so
weiter machen wie jetzt und da werden
wir nicht gut weg kommen da wird europa
nicht gut abschneiden
da sind länder die jetzt schneller
impfen die aber auch immer noch nicht
komplett öffnen weil sie 60 prozent
geöffnet haben und das turnier aus gutem
grund nicht weil es immer noch zu viele
menschen gibt die dann infiziert werden
sie reparieren auf frankreich und in
noch mal neben dem vermessen den ziel
glauben sie entschuldigungen wenn ich
darauf beharre glauben sie dass uns
jetzt am meisten zusätzlich ein lockdown
helfen würde
ein kurzer bundeseinheitlicher lockdown
um diese zahlen wieder runter zu greifen
oder sagen sie wir brauchen eigentlich
dann erst noch schlimmere zahlen damit
die politik das erklären kann
ja sie tut tja wenn das so ist dann wäre
das ziemlich traurig also ich weiß nicht
was intensivmediziner grad noch tun
können
sie haben ihre stimme sehr laut gehoben
und gesagt unsere intensivstation laufen
zu ich mein klarer kann man es nicht
sagen
und eigentlich ist es jetzt schon zu
spät wir begrüßen und da ist das
stichwort die hand celik oberarzt corona
isolierstation leitet er in der stadt
darum statt im klinikum dort herr doktor
celik sehen sie irgendeine chance dass
ihre station diesmal doch nicht so voll
wird wie im januar
also wir haben auf die wissenschaft
natürlich genau gehört wir haben uns
dementsprechend vorbereitet und wir
rechnen eigentlich schon damit und
merken dass jetzt auch in den letzten
wochen dass die neuaufnahmen immer mehr
werden dementsprechend haben wir unsere
station auch ausgebaut ganz pragmatisch
haben wir das getan
der ort an dem es nicht so gut
funktioniert ist natürlich die
intensivstationen die kollegen hatten
auch ein sehr nicht besonders tiefe
talsohle also die verschnaufpause
zwischen der zweiten und dritten welle
ist eben nicht so lang gewesen teilweise
sind patienten noch aus der zweiten
welle auf der intensivstation in
behandlung
das personal ächzte unter dieser
belastung und dementsprechend ist es
etwas unterschiedlich die situation aber
wir haben uns auf diese modellierung
eingestellt und bereiten uns
dementsprechend weiter vor dass noch
weiter viele patienten auf uns zukommen
glauben sie dass sich mit
in einem vermehrten impfen mit den
texten etwas an diese situation ändert
es gibt wie ich wir ihn korrekt zitieren
den vorsitzenden der deutschen
krankenhausgesellschaft gerald gaß der
hat sich aus dem fenster gelehnt und hat
gesagt das gesundheitssystem stehe
überhaupt nicht vor einem kollaps
da könnte man bei 5.500 erst davon reden
ich gebe gerne zu es sind nicht viele
die das behaupten
es behauptet ja das was warum sendet der
ein ganz anderes signal als sie das
müssen sie natürlich ein gast fragen ich
weiß nicht inwiefern er in der praxis
eingebunden ist also wirklich vor ort
sieht wie die situation auf den
stationen ist ich kann sagen dass
natürlich die ganze cupid behandlung im
krankenhaus andere bereiche verdrängt
das heißt eine geschlossene station auf
der fortan cupid patienten behandelt
werden bedeutet dass ganz viele andere
patienten eben nicht diese behandlung
bekommen zum beispiel planbare eingriffe
verschoben werden müssen wie
beispielsweise jetzt wieder an der
charité und in vielen anderen kliniken
auch und wahrscheinlich auch bei uns
wieder wenn es weiter geht mit diesem
anstieg auf der anderen seite sind die
intensivstationen jetzt wenn man das
register sich anschaut in unserem
versorgungsgebiet schon teilweise fast
durchgängig abgemeldet und können keine
weiteren coup patienten gut versorgen
gerade heute nachmittag mussten wir 50
kilometer einen patienten dem es
schlecht ging akut weiter verlegen also
das sind dinge die schon für eine
beginnende überlastung sprechen
wir sind immer noch von den absoluten
fallzahlen ungefähr bei der hälfte bei
uns im krankenhaus das heißt es gibt bis
zum absoluten maximum der zweiten welle
immer noch etwas luft aber ich warne
ausdrücklich davor die krankenhaus
belegungen die überlastung und die
intensivstation als maßstab dafür zu
nehmen
wie schwierig unsere situation ist oder
als maßstab für eventuelle maßnahmen die
verschärft werden sollten wenn es schon
so weit gekommen ist dann ist der karren
schon definitiv gegen die wand gefahren
und dann hilft das bremsen auch nicht
mehr
dann fragt man sich nur wie das politik
auflösen soll wenn sie auf der anderen
seite von gerichten vorgeschrieben
bekommt es sie sich nicht nur nach den
insekten richten sollen ja das ist
natürlich eine frage für die politiker
ich habe
in der letzten zeit jetzt auch in der
zweiten welle so ein bisschen das gefühl
gehabt dass gerade diese situation
dieser diese dieser umstand der
überlasteten intensivstation und
krankenhaus stationen und des
gesundheitssystems
das hauptargument zählt dass man darauf
wartet bis man dieses argument in der
hand hat um diese maßnahmen verschärfen
zu können wer als mediziner möchten
wirklich dass man diesen virus einmal
etwas zuvor kommt gerade weil wir jetzt
keine verschnaufpause vor der dritten
beraten
um wirklich mit einer niedrigen
incidents da raus zu kommen damit der
ende der pandemie denn dann das ist ja
wirklich unser gemeinsames ziel nicht
ein irgendwie kleines öffnen mit einem
test konzept sondern ein nachhaltiges
ende der pandemie das mit der impfung
wirklich in erreichbarer nähe ist und
das ist auch die perspektive die man den
menschen vermitteln kann viele menschen
fragen mich na ja wie soll das denn
hinführen mit den ganzen block downs und
in ist nicht bewusst ist das erklärte
ziel jetzt wirklich ist bis zum ende der
pandemie mit einer guten impfkampagne
mit einer niedrigen incident so schnell
wie möglich an dieses gemeinsame
zwischen zu kommen paul van dyk ist bei
uns produzent einer der internationalen
top djs ich darf ihnen ganz herzlich
begrüßen
paul sie haben ihr letztes konzert im
vergangenen september schon unter
pandemie bedingungen gegeben fand vor
2000 leuten statt und nicht wie sie uns
üblich vor 60.000 würden sie unter der
situation jetzt so ein projekt nochmal
wagen oder würden sie sagen es ist nicht
die beste zeit
ich glaube das muss man sich im
einzelnen immer genau anschauen und die
situation bewerten und natürlich müssen
hygiene konzepte auch entsprechend um
umgesetzt werden um dann natürlich auch
eine sicherheit der leute zu
gewährleisten und würden sie sagen dass
man sich
dass man tatsächlich noch mehr vertrauen
und mut verliert in der bevölkerung wenn
jetzt auch modellprojekte ins schlingern
geraten und sie in frage gestellt werden
nun ich glaube ganz ehrlich was im
saarland passiert das als modellprojekt
hinzustellen ist ein bisschen kurz
gegriffen für mich zur einordnung das
ganz einfach so wir haben demokratisches
system und letztendlich sind die
ministerpräsidenten ihren wählern auch
entsprechend schuldig was auch immer an
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
beschlossen wird entsprechend gegen zu
prüfen das werden sie machen indem sie
alle wissenschaftlichen gewerke
einbeziehen spricht nicht nur die
virologen sondern eben alle anderen die
im bauch maßgebliche entscheidungen zu
treffen haben dann in dem fall
und dann es ist die aufgabe der
ministerpräsidenten abzuwägen und
auszubalancieren was ist das beste für
die bevölkerung in meinem bundesland und
das ist für mich ganz einfach
der status quo wie er sein sollte das
für mich unser demokratisches system und
man sollte nicht unbedingt
während dieser pandemie alles das was
wir auch an an positiven demokratischen
errungenschaften in den vielen jahren in
unserem land erreicht haben und wie mit
dem hintern wieder einreißen und wir
merken ja jetzt aber und damit wieder zu
tobias hans dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz als solche
vielleicht in frage gestellt wird das
weiß man gar nicht ob das noch das
richtige gremium ist um sich zu treffen
noch mal die frage diesen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz termin
den gibt es nun nicht am montag sondern
höchstwahrscheinlich am mittwoch hans
und ich habe noch keine einladung
bekommen für mittwoch aber es hat am
montag wird es nicht geben da habe ich
auch noch keine einladung bekommen also
ich gehe mal davon aus es wird nicht am
montag sein
es spricht auch glaube ich vieles dafür
dass man jetzt nicht direkt am montag
zusammen sitzt wir haben momentan
erhebliche verzerrungen auch der
fallzahlen wegen meldeversäumnissen
deutschlandweit gibt aber ich würde auf
keinen fall so weit gehen und sagen die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist nicht
mehr sind
weil ich halte sie für sehr sinnvoll und
im übrigen haben die
ministerpräsidentinnen und die
regierungschefin den chefs auch immer es
geschafft wenn wir deutschlandweit eine
einheitliche infektions lage hatten auch
gemeinsame beschlüsse zu fassen wir
hatten ja bundeseinheitliche lockt downs
gehabt das problem ist eben nur dass wir
aus diesen lockt bei uns unterschiedlich
gut ausgekommen sind dass wir eben trotz
lockdown kontakte hatten die meist im
privaten bereich stattgefunden haben
dass jemand akte haben die im
arbeitsbereich stattfinden die wir auch
nicht durch home office und andere
lösung komplett in den griff bekommen
das saarland ist ein industrieland da
kann man nicht in dem umfang home office
machen wie das in anderen bereichen
anderen ländern vielleicht auch möglich
ist und deswegen ist es schon wichtig
dass man wenn es ein unterschiedliches
infektionsgeschehen gibt dann eben auch
diese parameter vor ort anlegt
bewegung ist deutschlandweit angespannt
und dramatisch dann muss man anerkennen
aber das bedeutet noch nicht dass sie
dort unbedingt dramatischen angespannt
ist wo niedrige instanzen herrschen
deswegen kann man im moment nicht
regionen und landkreise mit stabilen
infektions lagen in einen kompletten
locker und wohin das ist gegeben
herr hans ein paar kritiker dass es
ihnen wohl bewusst und wir fassen hier
nochmal drei zusammen das saarland hat
von anderen bundesländern mehr impfstoff
gegen mutanten bekommen und geht jetzt
ins risiko
das macht keinen sinn plötzlich ist die
gefährdung weg und das saarland
flächendeckend eine modellregion das
kann man nur
kopfschütteln zur kenntnis nehmen wir
haben auch neben der britischen variante
auch die südafrikanische variante dem
sehr hohem maße im saarland ist also
jetzt im moment auf keinen fall der
richtige zeitpunkt für die öffnung
professor thorsten leer klima kinder in
klinische pharmazie entschuldigung
universität des saarlandes ihn ist da
offensichtlich herr hans auch der
wissenschaftliche beistand ein wenig
verloren gegangen
warum noch mal die frage warum jetzt
und warum tun sie das überhaupt sie
waren ein großer maler und varna sie
haben vor reisen gewarnt vor der oster
ruhe von mutanten und jetzt tun sie das
nicht mehr warum
nein das tue ich und das habe ich auch
nicht aufgehört sie können meiner
regierungserklärung vom landesparlament
sich anschauen wo ich sehr deutlich
gesagt habe wir sind in einer dritten
welle und drohende anstiege der zahlen
sind da und ich habe nie gesagt dass wir
durch die pandemie sind oder das ist
jetzt irgendwie zeit ist für lockerungen
ganz im gegenteil ich habe gesagt es ist
wichtig dass wir vorsichtig bleiben das
tun wir auch im übrigen sie haben immer
gesagt leute reist nicht sie haben immer
gesagt da sind schlimme mutanten deshalb
80.000 impfdosen zusätzlich von europa
bekommen haben die sich alle aufgeregt
den es ab sich weiter hin und dann muss
man sich auch anschauen das im saarland
zum beispiel mit die strengsten kontakt
beschränkungen auch im privaten bereich
herrschen
wir haben nach wie vor in der eigenen
wohnung im eigenen garten derzeit
kontakt beschränkung von maximal zwei
haus ständen fünf personen das wird
kontrolliert das ist nicht in jedem
bundesland der fall und wir gehen auch
hin und sagen jetzt dass man im eigenen
garten zum beispiel mit zehn personen
zusammenkommen kann in der luft draußen
wenn man einen negativen test hat das in
anderen bundesländern völlig ohne testen
endlich gibt öffnungs modelle die ohne
test zum beispiel zusammenkünfte in der
gastronomie möglich machen bei uns nicht
wir sagen sehr deutlich wir wollen jetzt
keinen harten lockdown zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wollen aber dass menschen in
die freie luft gehen wenn sie getestet
sind wir minimieren das risiko ganz
erheblich und sorgen so dafür dass
kontakte die bislang ungetestet
stattfinden künftig getestet stattfinden
und das ziel ist regelmäßig zu test und
deswegen ist es weiter ein sehr vor
wichtiges modell es hat bloß kein
bundesland flächendeckend eine test
infrastruktur zum jetzigen zeitpunkt die
das möglich macht wir haben wir uns
stellen im saarland und wir testen frau
nicht das sagen darf wir testen unser
wir laufen in der nächsten woche wenn
die schule noch einmal zurückkommen auf
200.000 tests in der woche zu 23 prozent
der bevölkerung
und da muss ich dann schon auch noch mal
sagen gerade in richtung herrn ramelow
es wird immer gerne kokettiert damit
dass das saarland die hälfte der fläche
eines landkreises hat an anderen stellen
in deutschland und dann ist das eine
kleine region
jetzt wo es darum geht dass ein
modellprojekt gemacht wird ist es auf
einmal eine große region in
nordrhein-westfalen bewirbt sich die
stadt köln um ein modellprojekt mit
einer höheren einwohnerzahl
ich glaube da muss man schon ein wenig
realistisch bleiben und mit blick auf
die impfdosen will ich immer noch mal
sehr deutlich sagen
diese impfdosen bekommen wir von der
europäischen union sie gehen keinem
anderen bundesland achse sind dafür da
dass in regionen mit erhöhter mutations
lage das ist das saarland sowie das
nachbar département moselle und die die
b 11 7 variante dass sie eben die
südafrikanische variante entschuldigung
dass wenn die zurückdrängt und wenn man
sich anschaut wo die sich verbreitet
dann sind es insbesondere natürlich die
familien und angehörigen von industrie
arbeiten denn und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
person regelmäßig getestet sind deren
kontakte finden statt ich kann einen
harten lockdown machen bislang hat
niemand die idee gehabt dass man
industriebetriebe stilllegt in
deutschland wenn man auf diese idee
jetzt kommt dann müssen wir darüber
diskutieren ob das sinn macht und so
lange die industriebetriebe offen sind
ist es wichtig dass wir die menschen
dort mit regelmäßigen tests auch
hinschicken und das ist exakt das was
wir im saarland machen jetzt gibt es
darauf haben sie selber hingewiesen eben
die unmittelbaren nachbarschaft zu
frankreich frankreich hat eine 300
incidents frankreich hat ganz andere
maßnahmen ergriffen ist die gefährdung
an der grenze denn plötzlich weg in eine
gefährdung ist nicht weg und deswegen
testen wir das ist überhaupt der beginn
der saarländischen test strategie ich
erinnere daran
es gab die hochrisiko einstufung
frankreichs im hinblick auf die mutation
mit dem ergebnis dass man
gesagt hat es muss grenzkontrollen geben
ich habe damals gesagt ich möchte keine
grenzkontrollen und im gegensatz zur
grenze nach tschechien zur grenze nach
österreich gibt es keine grenzkontrollen
sie haben schlicht wegen des pflicht und
die sorgt dafür dass alle pendlerinnen
und pendler in keiner region in europa
wird mehr gependelt als bei uns es gibt
offene grenzen 20.000 ein pendler jeden
tag die kommen aus frankreich aus
luxemburg auch aus rheinland-pfalz und
die die aus frankreich kommen werden
alle 48 stunden getestet das ergebnis
ist die hohen instanzen und auch die
südafrikanische variante sie haben sich
nicht weiter verbreitet während wir
festgestellt haben dass in anderen
grenzregionen präsidenten sind wenn sie
einstechen wenn sie an österreich
begrenzt haben mit hohem nachbar
instanzen wir sind mit dieser strategie
erwiesenermaßen erfolgreich an diese
aber es gibt bei ihnen deutlich paul van
dyk gerade fragen auch mit blick nach
tübingen diese ausgangssperren die es in
berlin und hamburg gibt noch nicht halma
wünscht sich ausgangssperren weil er
sagt neben dem testen in den schulen und
in den firmen wären ausgangssperren
tatsächlich ganz wichtig warum machen
sie das nicht
ausgangssperren sind eine ultima ratio
und wir haben sie auch schon gezogen
auch sie sind letztendlich an
gerichtsentscheidungen gescheitert und
so umgesetzt worden dass ihr wenig
gebracht haben ich sehe dass sie
erfolgreich sind in vielen teilen
deutschlands und ich bin auch
grundsätzlich kein gegner von ausgangs
beschränkung nur gibt es im saarland im
moment keinen anlass sozusagen am abend
irgendwo hinzugehen weil es keine
kontakte geben darf da wir sehr strenge
kontakt beschränkungen im privaten
bereich haben also ich glaube man muss
schon schauen dass man nicht dinge
doppelt beschränkt und am ende für noch
mehr frust in der bevölkerung 3 3 und
das ist ja an anderen muss man auch
sehen das saarland ist auf zweieinhalb
tausend quadratkilometern sehr sehr
dicht besiedelt
kinder gehen regelmäßig wenn sie im ein
landkreis wohnen im anderen landkreis in
die schule hinein noch einem anderen
landkreis zum verein
da kommt man auch an grenzen was
ausgangs beschränkungen anbelangt
insofern muss man schon schauen wo macht
welches mittel sind und deswegen bin ich
auch sehr dafür
wenn man bundesweit einheitliche rahmen
setzt das ist eine gute sache aber dann
muss man trotzdem handlungsspielraum
lassen auf der ebene vor ort und das
sind eben nun mal die landesebene und
landkost fragen wir gleich ein ständchen
nochmal entschuldigung paul van dyk auch
tübingen boris palmer powell musste
jetzt die cafés wieder schießen der
bürgermeister sagte wir wurden überrannt
alkohol bleibt tabu und auswärtige
dürfen auch nicht mehr nacht für bingen
rhein ist es tatsächlich so dass die
menschen mit so freiheits angeboten
um es mal spröde zu formulieren mit
solchen freiheits angeboten einfach
nicht verantwortlich umgehen können das
eben wenn man den kleinen finger gibt
dann die ganze handwerk ist nun kann ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie für für
alle leute sprechen aber ich kann nur
sagen dass man sich manchmal schon fragt
bei manchen anordnung die es so gibt es
zum beispiel die ausgangssperre für wen
soll die eigentlich gelten weil wie das
gerade schon angesprochen worden ist
zwischen 22 und 5 uhr sind die meisten
von uns sowieso zu hause weil ja alles
zu ist und die die ihn nicht zu hause
sind weil sie irgendwo vielleicht
illegal feiern die halten sich auch
nicht an die ausgangssperre zwischen 22
und 5 uhr und insofern was auch immer
also wenn man boris palmer gehört hat
wie er das ganze auch kommentiert hat
dann sind sie letztendlich von leuten ja
überlaufen worden in tübingen die nicht
aus tübingen kam und einfach ein stück
weit freiheit und gesellschaft
gesellschaftliches leben erleben wollten
mit der konsequenz dass die die zahlen
dort entsprechend hoch gegangen sind
ich möchte aber an der stelle vielleicht
auch noch mal den punkt es gab gerade
die frage was sollte unser ziel sein wir
müssen unser ziel definieren und da sind
wir alle glaube ich gar nicht so weit
weg von das muss das ziel sein dass wir
im zweifelsfall über eine weitestgehende
immunisierung von uns allen die
möglichkeit haben gesellschaftliches
leben wie der stattfinden zu lassen
und es kann nur funktionieren das haben
wir auch nach einem jahr rum dr
möglichen lockdown varianten gesehen
über die entsprechenden impfungen und
ich würde mir wünschen dann würde in
unserem land endlich mal daran setzen
und versuchen das so umzusetzen wie es
sein sollte und natürlich auf dem weg
dahin begleiten mit maßnahmen die aber
im doch ein stück weit erklärt werden
ich finde den meinungsbildungsprozess
von frau merkel sehr schwierig weil wir
wissen doch gar nicht basierend auf was
schlägt sie uns eigentlich meistens ja
samstags schon vor was eigentlich am
montag dann in der mpk beschlossen
werden soll
das sind für mich alles sachen die die
stellen vieles in frage und und
natürlich müssen die sachen beantwortet
werden und ich finde es ist die
verantwortung unseres landes der
politisch agierenden dass sie da in dem
moment die ganze impfstrategie wenn man
sie denn so nennen will nach vorn
bringen und endlich mal zu dem punkt
kommen dass wir hier gemeinsam auch
einen schritt nach vorne gehen können
weil in der tat ein block nach dem
anderen
das bringt uns alle nicht weiter also wo
soll es denn hingehen also wir sind ja
eigentlicher weise also meine branche
seit über einem jahr anlockt und dann im
zweifelsfall wir alle gemeinsam seit
november jetzt heißt es dann plötzlich
brücken locker und was soll das bedeuten
kommt dann einfach ein zweites schloss
an den bereits geschlossenen laden oder
oder oder was soll da jetzt genau noch
passieren ich glaube wir müssen viel
viel transparenter miteinander umgehen
das muss ganz maßgeblich aus dem
bundeskanzleramt kommen damit die leute
auch wieder mitgenommen werden weil
ansonsten wird eben genau das passieren
was wir ja schon sehen dass viele leute
einfach den den den entsprechenden
regeln nicht mehr folgen und das hat
dann die entsprechenden konsequenzen
insofern kann ich immer nur wieder sagen
wir müssen impfen
darüber werden wir sofort diskutieren
klaus ruhe madsen der bürgermeister von
rostock hat hier in der sendung sehr
eindringlich geschildert wie die
situation bei ihm ist und hat immer
gesagt es ist nicht klug die leute jetzt
nach hause zu drängen in das private zu
drängen und genau deshalb müsse man eben
außengastronomie öffnen man müsse
möglich machen dass die leute sich
draußen und eben auch beim einkaufen
bewegen können damit sie nicht auf die
idee kommen mit dem nachbarn zu hause
die
flasche zu öffnen weil man eben in den
vier wänden manchmal nicht auf andere
gedanken kommt also frage glauben sie
dass man dass es den menschen wirklich
auch helfen würde zu weitere
beschränkungen zu akzeptieren wenn man
sagt draußen steckt man sich in der
regel weniger an und beim einkaufen
nachgewiesenermaßen auch nicht ich
glaube wenn die möglichkeiten gegeben
werden basierend auf den maßen amt auch
zu erklären sind
man kann ich einfach ein gesetz ändern
weil man in der im zweifel sich in der
lage ist seine maßnahmen zu erklären und
zu verstehen also die bevölkerung dass
sie den versteht sondern man muster im
zweifel 2 mit den leuten auch offen
umgehen und ganz klar erklären wir
müssen das machen um das zu erreichen
und wie gesagt ich bin kein vertreter
von von oder oder befürworter von sowas
wie logo wird weil unser leben findet
halt nicht in der petrischale stadt in
einem labor sondern wir sind eine
pluralistische gesellschaft wo viele
leute unterschiedliche bedürfnisse haben
die auch berücksichtigt werden müssen
und wie gesagt die gesellschaftliche
entgleiten die man feststellen kann
die müssen wir letztendlich auch mit
berücksichtigen in all diesen maßnahmen
und ja ich glaube dass es ein fehler ist
die leute in die privatsphäre
zurückzudrängen weil wir ja wissen genau
dort die entsprechenden infektionsherde
sind insofern ist es doch viel
sinnvoller und der entsprechenden
maßgaben und regeln den leuten
gesellschaftliches leben möglich zu
machen gegebenenfalls auch draußen
gerade jetzt in den monaten wenn es
wärmer wird so damit sind wir wieder bei
frau bringt man wissen wir denn
verbringt man mittlerweile mehr
ob und präzise ob die menschen sich eben
in den privaten räumen am meisten
anstecken oder nicht vielleicht wirklich
in den betrieben in denen sie immer noch
sitzen und ist viel zu spät darauf
geguckt worden dass wir auch in den
firmen regelmäßig testen wenn
arbeitgeber ihre leute nicht nach hause
schicken
ja also absolut wir testen viel zu
generell viel zu wenig und gerade in den
bereichen wo viele menschen
zusammenkommen und das ist nun mal sind
die bildungseinrichtungen und das sind
die betriebe und ich verstehe nicht
warum betriebe da nicht mit ins boot
geholt werden weil sie
natürlich durch die testung ihren
eigenen laden sauber halten aber auch
einen großen beitrag liefern für die
gesellschaft weil wir infizierte früher
erkennen weil wir eben nicht nur testen
weil ich will jetzt gerade mal opa und
oma besuchen oder shoppen gehen sondern
wirklich strategisch testen an den orten
wo viele menschen zusammen dessen schule
das sind die betriebe dass das sind
eigentlich das reicht würde tatsächlich
reichen denn da findet tatsächlich die
meiste mobilität statt im moment nicht
bei geschlossenen schulen wir wollen ja
wieder dahin dass wir sie öffnen können
aber ich will auch noch mal kurz ein
bisschen ausholen herr hans ich finde
dass ich finde es super dass wir
modellprojekte machen
ich finde es auch richtig dass sie sagen
warum mit einem kam über alle scheren
und warum nicht in den bundesländern
landkreisen die wirklich eine niedrige
incidents haben warum da nicht bereiche
öffnen das für mich total da bin ich
total der chor und das ist gerade auch
der ansatz der nur komisch strategie die
sagt dort wo das infektionsgeschehen
unter kontrolle ist
dort können wir auch nach und nach
bereiche öffnen
und wenn wir jetzt modellprojekte wie
das ihrige oder in tübingen oder
niedersachsen hat sich auch wild
beworben für modellprojekte dann finde
ich das gut und richtig aber der
zeitpunkt muss ja der richtige sein und
der zeitpunkt jetzt wo auf der
intensivstation menschen liegen und
sterben und die zahlen ja für sich
sprechen
in meinen jeder der die zahlen sehen
möchte sieht dass die intensivstation
sich fühlen und dass wieder mehr
menschen sterben
das ist einfach nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt für solche modellprojekte der
richtige zeitpunkt ist denn wir wieder
unten sind mit den zahlen